mi intención del día de hoy es
platicarles y decretar les que yo hoy
perdonó josé vasconcelos mejor dirán que
tiene que ver un cocinero con josé
vasconcelos o qué carajos tienen que
hacer esto aquí pero pues bueno les
quiero platicar un poquito de mi
historia imagínense pues ahora sí que a
un niño viviendo una infancia en el
estado hidalgo en un pequeño rancho
exactamente ahí que pueden que ver que
no hay nada realmente no hay nada ahora
así que esa es la realidad y si le damos
un poquito más de zoom pues no no hay
nada todavía vamos a prácticamente no
hay nada gracia damente esta foto la
saqué de google
y fue tomada en 2016 y pues yo salí de
de este lugar hace ya casi sin 15 años
entonces bueno hay un poquito más de
cosas por así decirlo pero qué pasa
entonces yo estaba viviendo ahí con una
mamá 100% regia mi papá es de la ciudad
de méxico y pues como que no había mucho
para donde interactuar estamos en el
kilómetro casi 36 más cerca del primer
pueblo que se llama me culpan entonces
de mayor interacción a mis hermanos mi
mamá no termina más 100% regia
posiblemente todo el tiempo me platicaba
y siempre estaba este tema
de lo que pasaba en el rancho con lo que
pasaba prácticamente en monterrey y
entonces de repente unos amiguitos ahí
yo estuve el kindle hasta que hacia la
prepa entonces nos invitan a una piñata
que se dice aquí en monterrey y todos
llegamos a esta fiesta y pues va
llegando la piñata y muchos picos no
color y ahí vamos la rompemos y sale
fruta no puede que la jícama ya saben
otras cosas y mamá me sea bueno en
monterrey realmente salen dulces esto
será como que guau no pus
monterrey monterrey no entonces queda
que regresamos a casa
honestamente no había internet no había
sky no había este tipo de cosas en el
rancho es más lo más divertido era a las
siete de la noche aprender la planta de
luz para que pues bueno todos pudiéramos
verlo
entonces platicamos mucho con mi mamá y
lo más padre de esto era que había una
interacción familiar y mi mamá realmente
nos platica de monterrey juntos nos
decía mira cuando yo era chica vivíamos
en san felipe que es por santa barbara y
cruzamos prácticamente por esta calle
llamada vasconcelos en la cual estaba la
pastelería que mi abuelo me llevaba
cuando yo era chica unos pasteles
preciosos hay una heladería preciosa
donde los helados eran de este tamaño y
casi casi se te rompen del cono entonces
desde ahí como que empezará a ver bueno
monterrey
de rey está divertido está padre y me
sigue platicando la calle como que mi
mamá insistía mucho en esta calle
vasconcelos entonces para mí era de hoy
es esta calle es la gloria esta calle
guau no prácticamente para mí era
entonces un champs élisée no yo ya me
veía con esa con esa idea no o sea vamos
a llegar a monterrey
champs élisée lo mejor de lo mejor pues
ahora sí que es súper padre no pero se
me quedó muy grabado ese nombre
vasconcelos
no era un no era un nombre que sea feliz
a da mucho ponían escuela que yo estaba
ni nada como que no no lo tenía
entendido entonces esto es bueno no no
existía este señor google que todo lo
sabe ahí en el rancho pero por lo que sí
teníamos era prácticamente en estos
lugares que es el centro de estés
alfajayucan es un pueblo más chiquito
todavía caben entonces llegamos
alfajayucan el papá tenía que ir a la
presidencia entonces vamos acercando y
prácticamente en todos los quioscos de
allá de hidalgo y sobre todo el centro y
nos hemos dado cuenta que mucho en todo
el país en la parte de abajo hay una
biblioteca entonces estudio llegó entró
esta biblioteca y empezó a preguntarle
ya pues tendrá algún libro donde venga
este nombre vasconcelos la calle unos no
sé quién es realmente y pues obviamente
no tengan muchos libros pero bueno
no sé si algunos se acordarán me sacó
una monografía una pequeña hojita que
puse ahí venían todas las fotitos y todo
el rollo muy poca información pero le
doy vuelta y veo no josé vasconcelos y
empieza empiezo a leer y me doy cuenta
que fue un erudito que es una gran
persona un gran filósofo gran escritor
por medio de la unam tiene lo que es el
doctor honoris causa no fue el
prácticamente el primer secretario de lo
que es la se trata de traducción pública
pues imagínense ese persona o sea
realmente un gran letrado el noveno
rector de la unam también entonces para
mí era una asociación de este peso de
esta persona junto con lo que es la
calle vasconcelos junto con lo que es
todo lo que llama me dice monterrey
entonces yo dije guau si una de las
calles principales que yo me decía y la
más transitada y por la que todo estaba
ahí lo mejor en champs élisée de
monterrey llevaba como nombre josé
vasconcelos y yo dije oye pues entonces
todo el mundo lo idolatran y todo el
mundo lo sigue y todo el mundo sabe
quién es esta persona y por ende puesto
los regios entonces van a ser así tú
dices que yo quiero ir a monterrey
yo quiero prácticamente hacer esto
quiero vivir allá quiero conocer esto y
pues bueno realmente fue un trabajo de
estar cuando será la oportunidad que yo
tenga para poder ir a vivir allá no
entonces pues bueno me doy cuenta este
gran señor mi gran ídolo vasconcelos
durante mucho tiempo siempre lo traje en
la mente y siempre decía quiero ser como
él quiero a la lugar donde lo idolatran
quiero ir con la gente que lo conoce que
prácticamente entiende por lo que este
señor está haciendo y más en una ciudad
tan cosmopolita como lo que es monterrey
no entonces pues prácticamente qué pasa
con el paso del tiempo me voy agregando
un poquito a lo que es la gastronomía
nada más no ahí está entonces yo luego
mis papás es que quiero estudiar
gastronomía me gusta el tema de la
cocina soy con melón cómo se pueden dar
cuenta me encanta comer entonces mi papá
me dice ok
quieres conocer la gastronomía lo
primero que tienes que hacer es viajar
entonces pues dime qué a donde viajó no
me sé tienes que ir a los mercados
tienes que ir a los pueblitos estos
empiezo a viajar a los pueblitos empezó
a dejar a los mercados hidalgo y me
empiezo a dar cuenta de esta mega
riqueza que encontramos no obviamente
muchísimos ingredientes súper padre dios
es que papá claro que quiero esto esto
lo que quiero de mí
mi mamá también la insistía más se le
quema el agua pero bueno mi mamá era así
como qué guay pues alguien en la familia
va a cocinar no entonces no es
prácticamente fue algo como que muy guay
y me dicen papá bueno pues obviamente
aquí en hidalgo no hay universidades de
gastronomía a dónde te quiere decir no
yo en ese momento fue es una oportunidad
ya la tengo ya sé a dónde quiero levantó
la mano corriendo luego papá me quiero
ir a monterrey mi papá me por una cara
literal de smet a esa situación a
monterrey ni si sabes la gastronomía ya
y yo tan feliz
yo voy sobre vasconcelos olvídate si
aquí hay mercado se hallaba a ver
tiendas boutique no
mi mamá literalmente suelta el llanto se
pone super feliz
nada mejor rodrigo corre ve que padre
que vas a mi tierra y lo más importante
de esto es que para mi mamá fue con mi
mamá fue esa conectividad de que todo el
tiempo me estuvo platicando porque sus
papás obviamente de sus bisabuelos de
toda esta cultura de monterrey yo la
trae muy en el corazón y aparte pues hay
que ser honestos pero está muy bonito
pero yo tener el nombre vasconcelos no
yo quería entender este tema entonces
busque lo que hago emprendo mi viaje
ahora si agarro maletas y vámonos a la
gran ciudad de monterrey no voy llegando
prácticamente del aeropuerto veo estas
hermosas montañas de aquí soy obviamente
en el estado hidalgo pues el trayecto
del rancho casi casi a la escuela en 45
minutos y no había nada no sé ni topes
no haya nada entonces nos llegó aquí y
voy viendo que casi esa distancia
yo la distancia del de la ciudad
entonces desde ahí ya íbamos ganando
prácticamente no y después que hago pues
llegó esta famosa calle josé vasconcelos
empiezo a verla aunque empezó a caminar
malamente lleguen a gusto entonces
empiezas en un calor estratosférico no
empecé a sudar horrible es así como que
algo está pasando la calle no está tan
chido
o sea como qué
preguntó sobre la pastelería este mes
entonces digo a ver tranquilo no pasa
nada hace mucho calor de la época vamos
a darle un poquito de chan seth voy a
tener mucho tiempo para poder caminar
esta calle y literalmente pasa una
persona él y como para cuando se está
bajando el calor mismos yo creo que para
enero en ese momento ya me dio un solo
pedazo bastante bueno entonces van a ver
tranquilos no pasa nada hay mucho tiempo
vámonos a lo que realmente venimos vamos
al tema de la gastronomía no entonces
los que pasa dentro y este tema de la
gastronomía
empiezo ahí a platicar un poquito con la
gente y puse en la primera clase de
gastronomía que tuve dicen a ver de
dónde de dónde son
vamos a levantar la mano y pues yo
sentado hasta delante no por ser
aplicado siempre tarde entonces estaba
lleno y pues ya estando ya está delante
mis hermanos todo donde era notorio soy
del estado hidalgo bueno afinación de
méxico pero para patata está toda la
historia pero ya estoy aquí sentado y me
dicen bueno y platicamos un poquito como
y si de alguno les digo bueno lo que
pasa es que mira el grupo yo sé que es
un lugar escrito no mucha gente lo
conoce es un ranchito taltal ahí en
transmitir con alfajayucan no entendían
los nombres pero
el 7 como que decía en este bonito
rancho a ver qué onda no pero entonces
empezó a platicarles sobre el tema de
los mercados este colorido que yo veía
esta interacción que me encanta sobre
todo el mercado de cómo si se dan cuenta
cada cuadrito está súper bien trabajado
con todo este tema ingredientes entonces
verdad me empiece a soltar y así me fui
se es que el mercado los ingredientes
como más o menos tenemos todo esto
correlacionado y sobre todo me dicen a
ver ingredientes como cuál es el es de
votos prácticamente tenemos los
escamoles que es un huevo de hormiga
considerado el caviar de méxico tenemos
chinicuiles que es un gusano de maguey
los siameses barbacoa de borrego symbol
patata empieza a sacar toda mi lista de
todas las cosas que me gustaban volteó a
ver y como la mitad de la gente tampoco
entendimiento yo como que todo esto y no
se haya ya me empezó a entrar este tema
de que está pasando y bueno ya me quedé
callado termine y sigue el de atrás no y
el de atrás levanta la mano y yo soy yo
aquí en monterrey y le pregunta el
maestro y en ese caso el chef que
también el chef era de la ciudad de
mexico entonces él se le dice bueno y
que encontramos aquí yo vengo viajando
de puebla teep y me gustaría que nos
platicaron como región que encontramos
aquí en ese momento voltea la banca me
le quedé viendo y dije ahora sí ahí
viene lo bueno ya por fin entender
y pues qué pasa empieza platicar ya
llegó a esto o no
entonces me dice carne asada y cabrito
y qué más
y se me queda viendo con qué cara se
está afrontando yo no haber perdóname
pero vengo desde lejos
hace un calor infernal es más último ese
manto heart es una carne asada pero le
pregunto literalmente bien no es posible
que no haya más el maestro está atacando
la risa como que me aventaba hasta
propósito
básicamente también están los rayos y
los hay
hay más cosas que hacer entonces
llevo ya mi casa muy cansado medio con
con sentimientos encontrados no estaba
mi mamá todavía no llegaron a monterrey
donde estaba quedando una casa que era
de que no había nadie entonces yo solo
no conocía a nadie ya lo estaba gente no
entendía cómo se prendía el clima
entonces dije es que ya usa este esto no
lo que yo buscaba esto no es lo que yo
quería lleva una calle con una gran
ilusión y no es la que yo veo lleva una
escuela con una cultura que yo quería
absorber y no es la que yo deseaba y
fusión esta mente volteó con una
computadora y digo a ver tú aquí sigo
con no existe este señor que sabe todo y
lo primero que prácticamente hago es
poner josé vasconcelos dicho yo está
esperando pues está este llamado divino
que yo creo que todo mundo hemos estado
esperando cuando ya sientes que él
mundos pequeños y me dices por favor
dame ss ss pues esa frase que más me
motiva
y buscar lo primero que espiritual
sí sí la digo es mentira lo pueden
buscar y así sale o no está tan padre
pero bueno si hacemos un poquito más
concretos literalmente nos dice jose
vasconcelos donde termina el guiso
termina la civilización y dónde empieza
el olor a carne asada empieza la
barbarie para la madre para ese momento
ya me fregó o sea ya ya me fregó ya me
fregó ya viaje que le voy a ir a mi papá
se empapa a regañar mi mamá va a llorar
qué carajos estoy haciendo aquí ya había
convencido a dos de mis hermanos que se
vinieran a estudiar lo mismo que yo ya
les había dicho que monterrey está con
madre y ni siquiera conocía pero ya lo
he dicho está en bruto
vasconcelos champs élisée o sea todo
este tipo de cosas es más de calor
huellas es poquito que hago realmente en
ese momento me sentí fatal honestamente
me sentí fatal fue un salud pasó
prácticamente yo creo que en todo
momento de la vida debe dar un momento
en que las piernas te tiemblan para mí
eso fue ese momento no todo lo que haya
dejado mi papá a su estilo siempre me
decía como no vais a monterrey o en
méxico de muchas cosas puedes irte a la
ciudad de méxico y guadalajara
para mí era una confrontación de decir
mi gran ídolo aquel que yo quería pues
me está diciendo que está en la judía
aquí entonces por ti me vine y llegando
aquí me entero que tú dijiste que aquí
estamos de la fregada no y la mente
dioses que no es cierto este gobierno
sabe no es cierto no te creo no te creo
y me sigo investigando un poquito y pues
prácticamente llega a un escrito donde
un sobrino de josé vasconcelos le pide
consejos porque está haciendo un estudio
sobre la gastronomía tamaulipeca y en
este es en esta carta que le regresa
cosemos con serlo demanda es entonces
hay si fue para mí el acabose
qué pasa si ya por me a la gastronomía
me esté diciendo estamos fregados pues
entonces yo qué carajos tengo que hacer
aquí hablo con mis hermanos
prácticamente los tres sentados
platicando este tema que pues ya como
que los tres ya estábamos ahí como que
ai wei la gente amor y decimos por qué
no decir el no creer porque no podemos
decirse es que esté equivocado porque
este ídolo que yo tuve durante casi diez
años luego existe es que no es cierto y
entonces qué fue lo que hicimos ahora sí
que nos subimos prácticamente a los
coches decidimos los fines
viajar yo recuerdo el que me ha dicho mi
papá para conocer un lugar tienes que
viajar tienes que conocerlo y tienes que
caminar entonces decidimos hacer esto
decidimos recorrer no los 51 municipios
que tienen nuevo león pero llevamos
alrededor cuarenta y tantos y empezamos
a caminar y empezamos a preguntar y
empezamos a hablar con la gente y nos
empezamos a dar cuenta y cosas demasiado
padres esa es la realidad
una de ellas la primera interacción que
tuvimos en el tema de pregunta fue
existe la carnaza hasta el cabrito
porque ya los probamos que aquí está
rico está padre pero por qué más hay
entonces todo mundo me decía como que
pues cuando hagamos una carne asada pues
ve a la creciera ramón está con ganas
diego ramos sí porque todo lo que vive
un chicharrón si lo pruebo si me gustó
dijo y esto es diferente
ya tenemos tres ingredientes en nuevo
león que padre ya la lista va levantando
volteamos los tres hermanos diciendo
lleguen hoy allá va por buen proceso
pero qué pasa no empezamos a
preguntarnos hoy de acuerdo confianza
méxico este chicharrón no le llaman así
o sea es más no existe ya es un
chicharrón seco grande y en querétaro el
chicharrón le dicen a las migas como que
había una particularidad que nomás fue
de noble 2 igual nos podemos investigar
vamos preguntando y vamos viendo y
llegamos prácticamente
nos vamos a regresar muchísimo en el
tiempo pero en el época de españa cuando
ya estaba este tema de conquista isabel
la católica' manda a la gente a que vaya
prácticamente a colonizar la nueva
américa no por así decirlo no nueva
américa entonces nadie quiere ir al
norte prácticamente nadie quiere ir aquí
porque porque es una zona muy árida
porque no hay chance dicen muchas cosas
entonces a quienes son los que manda
entonces en la parte norte españa
encontramos a este grupo de judíos de
árabes
entonces a ver a la católica por eso
lizana católica decide sabes que se
pueden ir a la nueva españa en la parte
norte y ahí prácticamente les va a dar
tierras le va a dar todo pero con la
condición de que se conviertan al
catolicismo no entonces llegan a la
conclusión de cómo puedo lograr que yo
me di cuenta que realmente son católicos
su religión no les permite el consumo de
puerco entonces lo primero que hace es
cuáles son los platillos típicos del
norte de españá y encontramos un
producto que se llama torrent su
historia es un chicharrón exactamente
igual que el de las ramos pero con piel
y es súper doradito es una chulada
entonces agarran y les empiezo obligar a
esta gente a darles de comer esto
y esto será la forma de que amante lo
comes ya ya no eres judío shas yo
explico ya te convertiste al catolicismo
ya es como que la palomita y vámonos
ahora hacia la españa entonces esto es
prácticamente esto es ya no judíos
sefarditas que es el nombre que se le da
al cambio de religión y entonces llegan
ya la parte norte y pues se dan cuenta
que hay china libre no es la realidad se
dan cuenta que aquí ya nadie nos está
checando en el norte todo regresan a sus
costumbres prácticamente vuelven a
regresar a pues ellos seguir
prácticamente con sus mismas tradiciones
y todo y entonces en ese mismo parámetro
pues llega a carvajal y organizó un
grupo de gente dice sabes qué vamos a
hacer la fundación de monterrey no como
tal vamos a fundar lo yo ahí en ese
momento como que me paré un poquito la
investigación y dije a cara y no era
este monte mayor el que fundó núcleo no
nos damos cuenta que no hubo tres
intentos de fundación de hasta el
tercero se logra no entonces primero
escarabajal bajo la ciudad de méxico con
el grupo de gente y le dice literalmente
a la gente con estaba reunida quiero
fundar no varió no quiero quiero fundar
lo es un lugar muy padre tal tal tal tal
tal entonces hay una comida que tienen y
el plato principal era carne de puerco
en salsa no
obviamente todos los sefarditas judíos
se quedan viendo y una sobrina de
literalmente dice yo no puedo consumir
entonces les llama mucho la entrega le
preguntan por qué no lo puedes comer y
ella malamente dice sabes que es que me
religión me lo permito en ese momento
capturan a carvajal me entra cárcel y
muere pero logra logra llegar ese
mensaje al norte aquí a monterrey y
entonces llega ese mensaje donde le
dicen sabes que cuidado ya se enteraron
que somos judíos y nos van a venir a
linchar nos van a venir a matar a todos
entonces que es lo que hacen cierran los
libros de la astronomía prácticamente
cierran todo cierran la cultura cierran
la tradición porque por un miedo y yo lo
veo que es un tema de supervivencia la
evolución o una civilización es aquel
que está tratando lograr llevar una
evolución entonces pues hay fondo nos
empezamos a dar cuenta junto con muchos
más ingredientes muchas más cuestiones
de que el nuevo león tenía mucho más que
ofrecer si nos hablamos en ingredientes
encontramos dos encontramos los nativos
como las maguaca estás que la vaina del
ébano la cual se consume riquísima
encontramos también los cambuches
encontramos miles de cosas la flora la
anac agüita el fruto anacahuita
encontramos miles y miles de productos
no ya están en el poder
pues ya teniendo toda esta información
los tres hermanos decimos es que vamos a
abrir un restaurante vamos a un
restaurante de cocina norestense 13
tiempos el más exclusivo chiquito porque
no hay mucha lana pero que esté bien
padre para 20 personas que funcione muy
bien y por la misma gente en un terreno
decía cristal oscuro ya ha habido
intentos de restaurantes de menos
distracción y no funciona la parte de
cocina no resistencia y que iban a largo
regreso al tema carnes hay cabrito y
nosotros oye se ve que no has viajado
por los municipios lados se ve que no se
entendió pero no te preocupes tú métete
a lo tuyo y nosotros seguimos con esta
ilusión y realmente llegamos a esta
ilusión los tres hermanos ya con el
conocimiento que teníamos con el tema de
ingredientes que teníamos sabes que
vamos a abrir este restaurante que se
llama col y actualmente es el que
tenemos les dijo está chiquito pero
bueno le echamos mucha potencia y mucho
amor y entonces empezamos a hacer un
desarrollo para el rey nosotros quisimos
cocinar para el regio y qué fue lo que
hicimos en este menú de 13 tiempos
empezamos a diseñar platos en los cuales
cada uno de ellos tuvieron historia en
cada uno podrán nosotros transcurrir
hacia la gente que llevará este tipo de
historias tuvimos en la parte de arriba
tenemos este plato que es unos cabuches
es un honor a la parte del sur donde
encontramos esta zona árida también
tenemos lo que es una fritada de melón
la misma técnica de una fritada pero
convertida en melón tenemos lo que es la
huasteca un plato que habla de todo lo
que es la huasteca como empieza como se
ve el tema de las piedras y todo ese
rollo tuvimos también otro plato que
hablaba prácticamente los tres intentos
de fundación tenemos lo que es el
meteorito que lo explica patricio re
bien este que es donde nos habla desde
para poder empezar a hablar de nuevo
léon que hay un meteorito rompe
prácticamente este pangea iv años
después encontramos el nuevo reino de
león' entonces realmente hicimos un
restaurante para el región o
internamente para mí se me va olvidando
más conceptos pero hay en el corazón era
como que uno va a fregar weiss lo voy a
hacer lo voy a hacer y luego a lograr y
luego a lograr y los tres hermanos muy
metidos en esto seguimos muy metidos en
esto y con el paso del tiempo nos
empezamos a dar cuenta que la mayor
cantidad de gente que teníamos
llega mi padre según ustedes tres que
están haciendo cocina norestense y así
fue cambiando un poquito el proceso y
pues con el paso del tiempo llegamos a
una gran bendición esa es la realidad
llegamos a este punto donde gourmets
hour nos domina como mejor restaurante
no 2016 fueron travel también nos domina
como mejor restaurante nuevo de todo
méxico 2016 marco beteta nos incluye en
su guía estamos entre los 120 mejores
restaurantes métrico es la parte padre
para mí mucha friega y bueno ya es un
logro pero hace no más de un mes y medio
y gourmets hour nos domina como mejor
servicio de todo méxico y también como
mejor menú degustación de todo méxico y
bendito dios lo ganamos en ese momento
que lo ganamos segundos tres hermanos a
guadalajara no nos las creíamos hasta la
fecha pero me sigue costando trabajo
creérmelo pero en ese momento regresamos
al restaurante con nuestro equipo de
trabajo que son los que se llevan los
aplausos y le decimos a todos señores se
dan cuenta que tenemos el mejor menú
degustación de todo méxico se dan cuenta
que por ende tenemos la mejor
gastronomía de todo méxico se dan cuenta
que nos fregamos ha hecho el comercial
apoyó la quinto ni la leche y cosas
y aparte siguen siendo los míos me dio
pena cuando nos dieron el premio con
jonathan pero pero les ganamos entonces
ahí llega a mí prácticamente un sentido
donde dije lo logramos hermanos la osa
lo hicimos contra los tres y
prácticamente en ese momento
llegó y diosa es que
jose vasconcelos
por medio de una carta que literalmente
le dijiste sobrino que estamos bien
jodidos pero no por la palabra entonces
yo decido hacer una carta a josé
vasconcelos y decide escribirle y decido
pues ahora sí que decirle lo que siento
entonces ahora sí que da planes que lo
valen se los comparto la hice hace una
semana ya después de los premios y digo
querido josé vasconcelos en esta carta
quiero decirte que estás equivocado en
el dicho que tanta furia e impotencia
nos dio los llamaste bárbaros y entiendo
que bárbaros son salvajes y que son
aparte incultos y nuevo león como tal es
el estado con mayor índice de empleos
formales en el país son el estado más
este más proactivo del país y somos el
estado que más ingresos del gobierno
federal y esto no creo que sea por la
falta de educación ya que prácticamente
contamos con grandes universidades
nos dices que no existe civilización en
el noreste y te contesto realmente
tenemos una trayectoria muy interesante
no nos destaque a nuestros gustos y
costumbres en primera tenemos una
herencia cultural impresionante es más a
mi punto de vista es la mejor
posiblemente tenemos tradiciones judías
sefaraditas por lo que podemos encontrar
con mayor arraigo en sabinas hidalgo en
villaldama justamente donde
prácticamente encontramos los riquísimos
panes la española como general terán los
ramones y los aldama en donde
encontramos esa longaniza que realmente
nos recuerda esa morcilla española y
aparte tenemos un poquito influencia de
la cultura tlaxcalteca que nos da sus
técnicas al vapor para hacer la barbacoa
los tamales y también otras hermosa
carne seca y también nuestra más antigua
cultura los pueblos nativos como
huachichiles borrados a las zapas que
nos da una gran cantidad de hierbas y
frutos medicinales nos dejan esta
herencia del mes que está mal y así cada
una de estas herencias nos hacen ser
luchones y ser aguerridos y por último
donde me diste el golpe bajo no tenemos
ni sub cara sino pura carne asada puede
decirte una cosa y si tenemos guiso de
hecho tenemos muchos tenemos los cauchos
en escabeche la flor de palm en asado
verde
el senado o el asado de puerco la frita
de cabrito y así podría seguir toda la
noche y en cuanto a la carne asada no es
un tema sólo de poner trozos en la carne
en un asador tiene una tradición que va
más allá y se remonta a la festividad de
la candelilla en higuera de nuevo léon
en esta que queman las varas de la
candelilla y en el baile alrededor del
fuego representa la vida nueva la unión
familiar y sucede a través del fuego
también representamos la esperanza sobre
las adversidades yo te digo josé
vasconcelos los norteños no somos
bárbaros ni somos civilizados pero si lo
creemos que sí lo somos pero lo que sí
es que no cabe duda que realmente somos
justos aquí en el norte y por eso te
pido perdón por la furia que me dio
tanto tu dicho y que realmente gracias a
tu terquedad y la mía de no creerte y
darte la contra sobre todo conocí mi
estado y encontré un pueblo lleno de
gastronomía con diferencias culturales
en cada municipio y con gran fraternidad
y realmente enamoré de nuria gracias a
ti encontré mi identidad como cocinar
honor extenso y gracias a ti por
decisión soy no leones nuestros propios
al escucharlos
[Aplausos]